so jetzt müssen wir den schalter
anzünden scheiße druck auf den schalter
nur geil viele tod nochmal bisher freut
mich voll
leichter gefallen das geschafft
nein ich dachte so alles hintereinander
oder leitern wo die leiter
naja ich kann jetzt checkpoint machen
noch zwei leitern du stehst da vor ich
kann weitermachen
die hier sind auch sehr schlau locker
wtf die teile sind irgendwie gerade
immer an
oder sehen fehler den hatte ich schon
mal mit spark valencia okay das einfach
wir haben einen knopf gedrückt und dann
waren die einfach die ganze zeit an cook
ist aber nicht das problem dass wir
keine leiter mehrerer christoph der
letzte check vor dem wir brauchen jetzt
kommentieren
ja ich hasse normalen gott oh gott das
ist richtig scheiße ich hasse jump
meldest du diese map man unbedingt
spielen
ich wollte nie ganz andere web spielt
welche dann die mit dem nein diese
länder an
mit dem mit diesem schlendern forester
ja aber die hat er nicht in verliert
gekriegt was für installiert war
die hat dann musst du den server machen
ich habe keinen bock seine komplizierte
mit zu installieren ist nicht
kompliziert doch die ist kompliziert das
denkst du was war daran kompliziert die
zu installieren weil man dafür noch ganz
viele mods braucht man braucht man nicht
nein ich jetzt fast geschafft
ich brauche man dafür motto da braucht
man mich einfach nur die map ja er ist
gericht und wie sieht man uns zu ändern
das ist ein endermann womit ein ans kinn
als wochen texture pack ja geschafft du
so laut altmann flotter als mich
zwar kann ich mich jetzt auch nicht so
laut verlierst du dir importieren
geht das doch es geht um sex hast du die
rein getan
solche rein getan die blöcke nein die
müssen wir erst noch finden
ich habe ein wohnblock auf diamond aber
auch ein
wo ist der dritte
ich hab ihn gefunden da wäre ich jetzt
auch eingeladen
okay gut aber da kommen nicht wieder
raus den kann man aber nicht öffnen
ja und wir kommen wir auch nicht mehr
raus er doch auf ich dachte du schlägst
mich doch da sind auch leiter ja wie
kommt man bitteschön hier raus
abgestimmt das geht ja gar nicht mehr
seit der es wegen alte version und so
das heißt wir müssen jetzt einen leiter
hier abbauen und die an der anderen
stelle wieder an platzieren was machen
er macht das war bitter ja und die
albert hamburg kiste geht ja auch nicht
auf ja das bringt aber nichts wenn wir
die reihen tun kannst du redstone nicht
das leitet kein redstone doch ist ein
repeater tram ja ein repeater hat einen
blog das war also ein repeater kann
einem blog bebauen und der macht ist ein
13 klippert blog das heißt er kann an
einer straight soll wasser dann legt
aktivieren
ja ok diese konzentriert nicht drin
bei mir geht die nicht auf hey leute bei
mir auch nicht aber den schlägt dabei
mir so komische dann liegt das irgendwie
keine ahnung da dran
keine ahnung daran von oben kann man ja
aber auch nicht aufmachen
ich versuche mal von darunter irgendwie
etwas drunter geht das auch nicht was
ich für normal
das liegt wenn man die paste glaube ich
geholt
dieser deckel soll der deckel ja die
habe ich auch gehört ja ok ja keine
ahnung dann liegt das daran ja da machte
ich kurz ein creative macht nimmt diese
decke da oben weg weil leute da können
wir ja nichts für das man ihn nicht
öffnen kann
das liegt einfach daran dass die
webinhalte version ist oder so dass auch
ein blog darüber blöder mitmache tasten
machen wir alles wieder normal
dann geht die tür hierauf man sind wir
in einer kiste und das dann in
wienerberger keine ahnung blog wegwerfen
da finden stil mein charakter der park
hast du mein card für mich mitgenommen
jedoch habe ich da die hälfte an der
tanke ich möchte da ein paar katzen geil
herr schenke blieb mein coach strecken
nein scheiße besetzung gefahren war mein
karte stehen geblieben arschloch du bist
wieder bei mir und ich bei mir auch egal
was dann fühle ich mich gleich was wir
jetzt wieder lange warten
so jetzt richtig hier gibt's dann ja
hast du hast das fernziel doch gar nicht
doch ich habe mich dort getötet deswegen
habe dann müsste das doch noch liegen
hier hast du das letzte mal hier ist so
jetzt müssen wir den schalter anzünden
danke ich nicht selbst ganz cool aus so
gehen wir mal hier rein
you can fly right through a
er verstehe ich jetzt nicht
wir müssen da rein werfen wahrscheinlich
so ganz viele verstehen nicht
hä
ach du scheiße das sind kommen wir nicht
hin wo ich bin
kombiniert kombi nicht hin war toll aber
wir wollen wir das denn jetzt machen die
man dann noch alle teams geworfen hat
auch das loch getroffen
verstehe ich nicht du hast jetzt alle
restlichen items ja ich habe alles auch
hingeworfen
das weist das meist auch getroffen
die können wir kurz nachgucken dünner
des triebwerks blablabla da ist ganz
viel drin
ja das habe ich auch geworfen jetzt
komme hier nicht mehr raus raus werden
die andere seite einfach nicht getroffen
auch martin du bist so blöd dafür musste
ich selbst ausgraben
warum hast du das sind jetzt die items
weg in london gut weil ich daran
gefallen wenn gott müssen wir wieder
frauen sogar einfach und gehör
unser geschafft das macht die gold
nugget sich alle geworfen hat diesen
alle drin
ja er ist offen die odlo luca fail
ja ich mache jetzt richtig so alle sind
drin ein
der gitarre aber da hinten das noch
keiner drin
warum man das war knapp alter der wahl
noch knapper sollte sich die richtung
die etwas andere loch da was
nein ich sage schon bescheid junge nicht
das loch das loch in die richtung ach
nee da habe ich doch schon einen drin
nein du hast in dem anderen ein drin alt
hat schild ich will dir gleich da sind
jetzt tausende drin ungefähr kommt da
noch rein muss irgendwo noch ein loch
sein wird sind die da wieder disappeared
oder so nächsten erst nach fünf minuten
das und noch mehr drin dass sich das ist
doch dieses loch lass mich keiner drin
ja stimmt nicht die große klappe und
dann bei mir gehen die alte weg die
items selber mir auch dass alle gleich
aber nicht weil er noch sonst ein
fleisch liegt
nein überall etwas drin
das fleisch ist auch von mir rumzulaufen
er wolle sich den wissen dass du es ab
post
doch überall was drin
denn da ist was drin das soll ist noch
offen
so bot das er als abzufackeln geben 1
ist also ich hab jetzt nach schalter
umgelegt dem einst finde stelle es
wahrscheinlich jetzt müssen als andere
finden und dann ist die haupt türe offen
das jedoch ganz sie erachten da kann man
drüber gehen ok ich ganz gott mein gott
oh gott
hier sind vier lava puls und in einem
rein springen einer ist der richtige
sein springst da da dam dam dam kanada
das ist so als sei ich würde sagen die
hintere linke ihn denn von den hinteren
meine hinteren rechten martina springt
du erst mal rein
dass darunter das ging runter aber es
war falsch jetzt mal die auch unter ja
es war aber auch falsch oder dass das
war schon richtig aber wir mussten
vielleicht ein bisschen nach vorne gehen
oder so egal das erst mal wieder 1 1 und
2 also vorne links und vorne rechts ja
ich gelegen ist falsch ich war direkt
die ganze zeit in der ersten reihe aber
nein ich bin ja dass der vorne rechts
das ist der richtige aber ich bin
gestorben bist du dann weiß ich nicht
es war wichtig einfach mal was los
ich bin runter gefallen während ein
arschloch
ok ich hab's geschafft game 2 findet und
ich bin so die finals offen aussprach
keine scheiße weiter auf mich warten auf
mich wartet auf mich ich bin gleich ihr
tut muss man so komische mecke achten
verreckt man dann eben dich weil man so
lange leben in den flammen drin steht ok
den ersten die ersten spiele euch
geschafft
nein ach das sind decke
geld geld geld geld erste sport das ist
total cool ist eine platte wo kein feuer
ist ich sterbe respawn und los geht's
schon mein vater martin zu und jetzt ist
martin toth
ja und ich bin auch so toll
und ich bin tot tot tot soll den ohrwurm
und ich brenne gibt es keine kopie red
wings nötig wenn wir selber sinkt das
kann die gema nicht feststellen oder
wegen so gut wie die das geschafft ist
jumpstart boah da muss man die tür
öffnet dabei dann rüber springen das ist
blöd
die us-studentin anderen geschafft ich
bin ziemlich mit abgesprungen ach
verdammt